i wrote this
piece that went viral even though
all these publishers were telling me
this audience doesn't exist but it was
the battle cry of the politically
homeless and i think i wrote this in
2017 or 2018 and talking about how
they're i felt this authoritarian creep
coming from both sides nobody likes to
hear this but i was feeling it on the
left around speech you know regulation
and what you could and couldn't say and
all of that and then
on the right obviously there's just um
the kind of despotic attitude of trump
at the time and that the cult of
personality around him is terrifying to
me just that demanding fealty from
everyone around you
and so
those two kind of forces really are what
pushed me to the middle more than
anything and i started an email address
i am politically homeless at gmail.com
and told people to kind of write me
their story i got thousands of emails
from people and
telling me their story of transition now
whether it was from the right to the
left from the left to the right
some anarchist who became radicalized
into voting somebody who hadn't it was
so many fascinating stories from all
types of people all walks of life and
then in 2020 i
kind of circled back and had people
write me right before the election about
how they were feeling were they hiding
their vote from their spouse
and the thing that struck me the most
was the people in 2016 who were maybe
reluctant or sheepish as you mentioned
voters of trump were
all in on trump or they regretted not
voting for trump in 2016. there was i
had so many hundreds of emails of people
who were saying um
exactly what you're mentioning and then
there were people who were on the other
side who had been
voted for trump and thought that he
could like
hold it together and not be trump and
we're so disgusted by him that they're
like i'm voting blue all the way down i
don't care so it was interesting
i think every and i just had a really
interesting discussion with this guy
jesse morton about
radicalization and hyper polarization
and we were talking about how everyone's
being radicalized
yeah increasingly for sure
yeah so how how did your i mean did you
have any personal loss from your
announcement that you are leaving the
democratic party did you personal loss
in terms of relationships and friends
and people
or did it not really affect you that
much
i have
many many friends who are avid democrats
as you'd imagine because you know i've
traveled the country for the last number
of years running for president uh and
mayor as a democrat each time
um and so yeah it's
put a cramp in a lot of those
relationships
uh i will say though that i see those
relationships as
um kind of a hybrid between personal and
professional
like are there friends of mine who i
consider friends who called me and said
hey i'm not gonna be friends with you
anymore like no i haven't really gotten
that
[Laughter]
you haven't been disowned or anything
yeah i mean certainly my parents could
give a i mean yeah i actually went
to my parents because i talked about in
the book how
i'm the son of immigrants and i have no
idea what my parents thought about
american politics so i actually went to
my parents was like hey
my mom
hey mom did you like
vote
[Laughter]
and please don't judge my mom but the
answer was no she was like i didn't
really understand american politics i
came here and you know like uh
um just kept my head down
um so
um
so my my friends
uh
i think a lot of people within the
democratic party that knew me know me
um don't consider me like a you know an
they're like okay yang's doing
something that maybe i don't agree with
on this one um but we'll see where it
goes that there is this massive fear
that the reason why i started the
forward party was so i could run for
president in 2024 and that a lot of
democrats fear that i would hive off
more democratic voters than republican
voters
um that there's a concern that you know
i'm just driven by naked personal
ambition right which i mean i laugh at
because you know like
certainly
um
like if my goal was to you know achieve
like the
um the most political support i could
like
one of the things you experienced too
and i joke about this is like no one
puts themselves into
the equivalent of the political
wilderness out of some you know what i
mean out of some like self grandiosity
this is really going to be the thing you
know
because you know immediately you you
wind up
um in like a
a
zone where you don't have like this
infrastructure and this is one thing
that i'm very interested in working on
because i think the country needs it
very badly and i dare say that you're
you're already kind of a forerunner to
this
bridget like you you're the prototype
without even knowing it
that there should be some
independent media
we need our own
set of voices that are people in part
for all the people that reached out to
you and your i am politically homeless
at gmail to let them know that they're
not alone and they're not insane
i've seen the the most inspiring thing
over the past couple of years for me has
been seeing a lot of people
pivoting into that space the glenn
greenwald barry weiss a lot of the
people who were
maybe of the left or in left wing media
kind of
shaking off that brand and and coming to
be more independent labeling themselves
independent
i think that a lot of people
resonate the problem that i have and i
still haven't been able to figure it out
is how do you galvanize that energy
because there's so much energy
but so much potential energy so much
potential energy and it's also just a
group of people who i think feel so
disillusioned and apathetic which was
something that i loved about your
campaign
is that
you made me feel optimistic you know
most politicians to me are so deeply
cynical i mean
i i find
i find like kamala for example to be so
phony it's offensive
and
and it's just the way i react to her on
a natural just it like affect affects me
viscerally just so and i think trump you
know i always used to say people are so
hungry for authenticity they'll choose
like an authentic over
somebody who they feel is just a
hillary kind of hoover a phony political
actor yeah and you broke through that
and i know you mentioned a lot of the
kind of moments you had which i loved i
loved that that first section of your
book that your story because i love the
stories
and seeing you
create all that energy
um was exciting and it's it's just
how do you
how do you break through i think at the
end of the day what happens is people
want to want that but then they get
scared and they retreat to
one side or the other because they feel
like it's hopeless and they're you know
i i got to i told everybody this was the
other time i got absolutely
buried was at the election i was like
i'm not voting not voting for anyone
not for the two major parties and people
on both sides accused me of throwing the
election for whatever the you know
whatever side they were on
like your one vote in california was
gonna beat it yeah
which by the way is but they were just
like you shouldn't be saying this and
even putting this message out there and
i think people who even dare to say i'm
voting independent get so piled on by i
talked to a woman who's a
media figure who just said like hey i'm
voting third party and just got piled on
oh yeah mercilessly it's not even worth
it to to to say it and so people i don't
feel like
that's what i mean how do you galvanize
all this potential energy of people are
scared to even stand in that space and
admit that they're there
because yes you take so much or this is
the other part of it bridgette is that
they're rational
and paying attention to politics is
depressing right so the rational thing
to do is just be like it like i'm
just going to ignore it
and if i'm going to vote third party or
not vote i'm not going to talk about it
right
like this is a very uh rational set of
moves
uh and and so the challenge and i i tell
jokes about this sometimes it's like the
challenge is to get people to join who
are by their nature are not naturally
joiners right
right that's my twitter bio is my tribe
is tribalist you know it's like how do
you how do you create
a
kind of center out of something that's
kind of centerless then and that is by
nature a lot of these independents they
are by definition independent so
and it's hard to i think to capture and
you see this within libertarianism
there's like such a big umbrella of
who is captured under the libertarian
umbrella
and there's the more right-leaning folks
and the more left-leaning folks and the
anarchists and
i think within this kind of politically
homeless disillusioned you have people
who have wandered in from the right but
they still on principle
or even maybe on social things might
lean more right and then you have people
from the left and
if it comes down to single issues where
we're just somebody in the middle how do
you even manage to
bridge that divide even within
such a disparate group of people
yeah the the problem you're describing
has been called the mushy middle is that
how do you create a coherent party out
of the mushy middle
one group of people that have reached
out to me since i started the forward
party that i've been encouraged by
is military veterans and ex-law
enforcement who are not into trump um
but who are not democrats and they're
looking around saying okay and a number
of them have reached out to me and said
i've been waiting for something like the
forward party thank you and that made me
really glad
uh there are a couple of consistent
strains
of
political ideology that are attracted to
this kind of movement
people who are
principled patriotic
don't think that either party is working
uh right now
i love the people that i've
made common cause with this last number
of weeks months
uh i'm a big fan of yours bridget just
thank you for this conversation but
there is something
um profound about people who've kind of
taken off the blue hat or the red hat
uh and then looked around and said oh
and in many cases by the way have to
walk through
a lot of adversity or verbal pummeling
and then that shapes you in a particular
way you're like wait what happened and
then you're on the other side of it it's
a little bit like high school
it's a lot like high school
[Music]
you